hello welcome to this broadcast I hope
I'm life because well it we changed
something again trying something new the
video is looking a little bit different
today yes you see I'm kind of melted
into the background we we try and a new
um yeah in a way of um getting the BAP
cam into the into the broadcast so yeah
please let me know how this looks how
you like it so I'm going to kick off
with a couple of five-minute games as
usual I'd like to play some so what do
we get here I'm a beast that's cool so
it's a GM also um no no and no name in
there so we just have to be content oops
that was a bad idea now we just have to
be content with the information that
it's a GM but we don't know much more
okay I'm going to play them each three
line against the Kings Indian align that
I have played quite a bit over the years
I'd like to know it better but yeah i'm
going to try it anyway it's in fashion
nowadays so yeah night age five and he's
going for f5 I think g3 is what they
normally play nowadays the old movies
night to h2 but the Sun has lost them
yeah popularity quite a bit um
I think they take and go night age four
and i'm not mistaken and yeah but i'm
kind of inventing stuff as I go along I
really I already don't know it precisely
there's also maybe Knight to f4 here I
wonder if this kind of move order was
correct anyway let's see Bishop b2 it
probably has to go back back to f6 and
what now hmm yeah i'm probably going to
go for a long castling anyway like
bishop soured Queen d2 or something I
wonder if Bishop e3 can be answered with
F form do I don't really buy that F form
maybe you know okay
so let's continue with normal moves
night c-54 night efore might be
something 94 hmm I wonder Bishop h6 is a
move while if that is some far too slow
I always like to trade off those bishops
in the King linnean I really have a soft
spot for that so I'm going to do that 94
I can take 94 Quincy one and I don't
mind that position it looks kind of okay
yes bishop is also a potential
potentially good piece down the long
diagonal it um it covers the king and as
I said it can be really active there so
my basic ideas to maybe to capture on g7
and play let's say Queen III castling
long maybe f4 or maybe castling short
actually there's no particular reason to
go with long Castle anymore hmm I think
something like f4 must be there the
critical test of what I'm doing him
something something dynamic if he allows
me to capture and go like Queen III and
f4 oh that's one interesting that's
interesting let's still go back and they
have that f4 idea the reason why queen
is three years seemed interesting to me
or putting the Queen there is that now
f4 can be simply answered by Queen takes
e4 so that's a pretty simple way to
prevent a form yeah I wonder ever should
play a for now or is that is that badly
time
I can do that first and then f4 yeah
that's a pretty good position i think
for what unless i'm overlooking some
dynamic that I don't don't understand
from a purely static point of view that
is a very nice position because f4 will
fix the spawn f5 and give me some very
direct play school here I have to do
that anyway step step aside hmm now okay
but I have rooted g1 I wonder if he may
be this Bishop only two could prove to
be a problem a liability okay
yeah I didn't do an announcement video
today on my on my own channel and it was
simply due to the fact that I was too
busy today I couldn't simply couldn't
make it so hmm I would love to take me
with the Queen but he might have night
XD 3 that's a shame can I have to don't
have to check with that which is no
problem really I think night back here
why do I give the check on the forum
let's start with that move nothing wrong
with that idea
what is he doing now just maybe queen of
six on that makes that makes sense
simple move now I can take and watch now
Bishop d3 well maybe attack the pawn
down
yeah that looks like a pretty nice
position yeah some people may have
thought that there would be no stream
today up maybe but I'm basically on
every Monday I was on vacation of course
but one on regular Monday's I'm online
really absolutely every Monday so okay
he gave me their five porn maybe there
was no alternative to that so okf night
age 64 night f7 mate which looks like a
pretty tricky thing for him looks like
he has to play some passive reply to
that night at seven mate if he had to do
that and now well he really cannot move
much what why would you do that what's
the best way to go about that g 5 f-5 is
not right it's not a bad idea he cannot
really go if i go to f5 he cannot really
go King g7 because of rook f now almost
you gave six hmm
look at five King g7 well there's no
really good reply down
I want to go to f3 and threaten ruge f5
you cannot move the they couldn't then
move the night as well an idea for the
move I forgot about 94 ok so that's not
good that gives him far more play than
necessary really harm one
yeah what a bad game I mean not a bad
game he had completely outplayed the guy
but I completely froze at the end that
was bad the final was pretty bad of that
ah what a shame yeah I mean I'm just
completely winning off cause I'm like
around here huh but how should I have
done that his deep one got far too
dangerous I was too I was too focused on
those source tricks with Rugare five
probably okay let's get a new game and
see what happens
yeah I could have played played that
much better near the end of that game
yeah I have to really restore my rating
23 something doesn't sound too good I
usually am around 2,400 something deep
black grand master who is that stair
named Carlos Garcia Palermo ok so a
second GM in a row and let's see I'm
going to follow the names oh my main
opening and see if I can get something
in from my from my book yeah that's
interesting line before you five is
particularly interesting yeah they're
not that many viewers i miss that miss
that announcement video yeah i was
simply too busy today the main thing was
that i'm also helping to organize things
in my in my chess club and today we had
to had to yeah enter all the teams for
for the upcoming for the upcoming season
y'all like who plays on what board and
stuff like that which is really tons of
work and yeah it took so long that i
couldn't really do much else let's say
so yeah that deadline is pretty pretty
harmless for like it's not terrible for
wider anything but it's a bit difficult
for white to to find anything anything
great iam black has a good term yeah
good space advantage even here on the
King side and what you can do is we can
try to pile up on the H porn but this is
not particularly dangerous
so black has no problem here whatsoever
the question is do I play it with c5
with c6 there are there are a couple of
ideas that that make sense yeah we're
going to start with that it's not quite
clear what what's best but that's not a
bad move okay King be honest yes typical
he wants to go see five really okay
let's stop that if he takes Knight eggs
i have bishop a 394 and a very nice
position so it's not going to work okay
is moving the night away the question is
should i take on g3 or not if i take
there and play Queen f 2 i'm trying to
wind material already wow okay yeah the
thing is he cannot even take them I
cannot take here I can oh sorry I'm
sorry he can take that but but I can
play Queen f4 I mean isn't that kind of
annoying it would it'll takes a little
bit of time now to arrange that Queen
you one yeah the thing is i have i have
to move g4 even if i want which is not
bad on 96 which is also not bad hmm
tough the same it smells pretty good g4
is also good
yeah okay I don't I don't mind really
it's it's both continuations are pretty
okay so what now okay if he takes on g
three with a night there's this night h5
idea which is a bit annoying maybe the
other the other one was better anyway
nice God ruka h5 actually I was planning
Queen g5 i was planning Quincy High but
that wasn't a good idea okay so what I
played was was not good instead of like
being better now I'm in trouble and I
could have had a very good position huh
that's a bit of a shame
it's a real shame from that great
position that I had what happened to him
fatigue f3 is going to regret from
Warner and I have no at the bishop is
hanging hmm so what is he playing we
should be for my queen doesn't have many
squares it's really not not very
convenient
so let's see hmmm so rook to h5
I wanted to go 98 96 if possible it's
very slow
so i was saying i would say that white
has at least a slight advantage in all
lines in his books what do you mean my
book I don't think so I mean I'm not not
producing a black rubber to a book where
why does better in every line that's not
true there are two or three lines where
wide retains a very small advantage but
that sets all of it yeah what now I
didn't see how my queen is strapped
immediately this is why I allowed that
but it looks tricky quite clearly there
should be two or something I go Queenie
for then with check
okay so I'm just going back now okay it
can take at five here and then what will
gauge 50 I hope chief of course yeah I'm
very slow what is he going to do maybe
that's also not greater hmm
Group chief awesome is a real annoyance
and it's also great wow wow
yeah it's not that simple i'm playing
really badly here right while i was
spoiling that position is really a shame
white white wasn't in good shape like 12
moves ago and i managed to really screw
that up royally huh wow i couldna
strapped ok around here i have a really
good position just I mean I totally
totally misplayed that I just he has a
bad bishop and basically no plan in this
position and I completely killed myself
Wow ok um yeah there's someone asking
God jeans go I just asked he said um
people would stop playing d 4 against me
now that i published a book about
meeting it no i don't think so of course
i will i will play some things i will
play some things from the book but it's
part of my regular repertoire but i'm
not going to play those openings all of
the time so i don't think that there's
any particular change to expect them ok
we got another Kings Indian and I really
want to win games there but it's pretty
bad having to better positions and
losing both games that's really not good
I mean the first position was really
winning the second one was just an
advantage but I just I just lost both
games pretty badly
so I'm going G form as some white
usually does in those lines gaining
space and trying to prevent blacks play
on them on the King side yeah that's an
interesting interesting try ok I'm going
to do this and go h5 simply opening up
the Kings side those positions are very
difficult to play even even though
sometimes um yeah black is not in
particularly great shape it turns out to
be very very difficult to play so on its
own toilets tricky
that's a question if I if I release
another book in the future what will it
be about I'm probably not going to do
another book I have some other ideas and
in terms of when it comes to publishing
chess content but it's probably not
going to be a book or let's say I'm yeah
I'm a book that a book like the one I
had published now I will definitely put
out details about those projects but
it's not yet something that is some yeah
all together that clear what what what
I'm what I'm going to do exactly okay he
wants to put his night there to f4 um
yeah okay I can take you can't just take
h5 I want but it's never it's not the
best move pretty much mmm tween f6 is a
possibility that you might have
one night ever I'd like to play Knight
c4 I mean I make movie can't play nazi
for anyway Bishop h6 s also move that
could happen yeah that's a that's a
tricky position I mean this is the kind
of thing if you give it to a computer it
will win with whiter every game but it's
took kind of tricky our King is only one
and hmm yeah not easy
I didn't greet elite take upon as
someone rides in the chat what I did is
I I completely won the light squares
with that and I have some problem here
with the Queen on g5 there is a dark
square problem definitely that sets too
but it's not I wasn't grabbing just a
pawn that's it simply not the case Queen
d2 may be on yeah it's not easy it's not
easy to play especially for a human
Quincy to quincy to as a move a tricky i
am queen g2 can happen mmm that's too
bad yeah I find h1 saying I'm cheating I
am playing to a bit to Lucia I think ya
should i should play anymore a bit more
solid fashion even I mean you shouldn't
try to punish the other guy every game
like so hard like I'm trying to do um ok
Wow now you for still hang
yeah Queen d2 was lousy I just saw Queen
g2 far too late yeah and now it's it's a
huge problem Bishop age six is a huge
problem in particular Wow
yeah black hat number of good moves that
is just one of one of them but at least
I have the deep or now that still seems
kind of interesting at least a little
bit 9 f 43 is probably killing all the
counter play though when the knight hits
d3 that doesn't look good now anyway I
have to push the deep one everything
else is kind of useless
okay so if i go d seven cakes takes mmm
I'm not promoting now i'm really not
promoting it's a shame night over there
don't even play Knight b6 Wow 97 he can
even even take takes you form I have no
moves yep Wow
it's taking that that's probably also
okay
rupee to King c1e can just take be five
probably I didn't play the most precise
ER way probably but it still wins
yeah okay wow I have to I have to get on
the scoreboard yeah another GM that's
cool yeah there's a Julian auction here
ok guys i get them getting GM after GM
that's cool some i mean i'm not in the
best of shapes give me some easier
position please ok so let's try with a
solid Queens gambit and see what auction
is doing against it splaying a form of
the exchange variation yeah here queen
bee three is critical but a dream aged
30 why not yeah this GMO it's a pretty
good GM that Julian auction he's a 2 650
guy only retired he's a really good Jam
not not your average scan of Grandmaster
so will it see what happens here he
fianchetto with his bishop and I thought
maybe I can can use this Hecht somehow
to my advantage but I'm not quite sure
the Queen on b6 is kind of debate about
them let's seem yeah someone writes no
gambits tonight maybe I should play a
crazy gambit and that would help but I
don't know I don't know if that would
help so I'm giving that up but I want
better control that way you form let's
do that Knight to e5
sorry going to go f3 now not trade stuff
now this one am gaining gaining some
space there on the Kings side mmm it's
not a terribly bad position I think
before I'm not sure about really that
looks it looks normal but it gives me a
potential Knight to c4 not sure if I
manage that but it's a possibility
whenever I move this night though his
Bishop might invade somewhere on if I
ever somewhere around from down okay
maybe get this out of the way first so
that Bishop t6 is not coming with the
tempo he's playing it anyway so where is
he going is he really going to see five
it's hard to believe it's almost a self
trap what I go b6 and what then let's
check here and then be six okay yeah you
have to show me now I think the bishop
is strapped maybe there's a tactic that
I don't understand but ok that's that's
not really going to work but objectively
at least but it's maybe still a bit
tricky so pawn takes if I have to go
Knight f6 I guess to cover g5 and jump
into e for the right moment
well so I'm a piece of maybe then maybe
that's that's a winner it would be nice
it would be nice to get a win in here in
that stream so just 94 I was thinking
yep let's do that to our objects i Luke
Texas is making a bit more sense
actually intending deform and try to get
at its King have this extra piece and
should use it yeah okay but that that if
I don't win that I might as well stop
with this it's topped with this game
it's it's really just a complete win so
um rookie seven on nail probably rook c4
is a move now next just took c4 or d-4d
for us also good yeah if he takes rookie
two will be will be a mating attack
okay so he doesn't really believe that
but it is a maid ride let's check made
with queen of six so we resigned yes no
we didn't play the trump that was a
Queens gambit I play d4 d5 avoiding the
Trump oh yeah so okay so at least I got
a win in but still it was a pretty bad
start with those three pretty much
uninspiring losses from two good
positions or maybe three even but um
yeah my my tactics are very very very
very off after that long break I really
have problems with the slightest kinda I
I never played vishy anand or Carlton
Carlton only has a kid online and i see
i played Hikaru Nakamura a couple of
times losing about every game I have one
game with on video that I won against a
camera it was quite funny but my overall
score must be something like 3 out of 50
or so it's so real coincidence that i
really gotta win on video and i lost
tons of games especially in the pre in
my pre video a time let's say um also
because Nakamura was playing a far more
games years ago nowadays is really a
ended good for him let's say focused on
yeah on classical chest trying to be a
real challenger to Magnus Carlsen so I
only very recently looked at this a bit
and I must admit that i forgot most of
it that depth that line is very much in
fashion but
mm-hmm I think I have to start with
Bishop e7 huh but I think I can take
here and go Bishop e7 right this is one
I guess not pledge for him well I don't
really know that line I only looked at a
couple of I've I only looked at a couple
of games and I don't really yeah
consider myself being anywhere near
knowledgeable enough to to claim that I
know what I'm doing hey yeah i got the
recommendation to do some to do some
chest temp or tactics um yeah yeah
you're right i mean it would be helpful
to get my tactics um a little bit back
into gear but yeah I have to find the
time first and well my my own my own
player is important to me but not as
important as some being a good teacher
and let's say good broadcast and so on
this is some my main focus nowadays okay
today about that game now that that's
nice here I got Queens traded and this
is a good end game here for black um
that's a question what is the best
entire French line to play as what if
you're someone who does not like to play
in French type positions hmm yeah that's
not so easy um if you don't like to play
against friend in French type positions
it's maybe something that you share
should work on because um I mean many
French type positions are rather good
for the white I mean not like the fringe
is a bad opening but in many cases white
has got more space and so on according
to most classical principal said
something that it's pretty good
so maybe it's just that you have to yeah
improve your you play in those in those
positions and not your form not go for
some weird line to avoid the structures
um I usually recommend the not a 92 with
the tirage in many cases after c5 it
gets more get more open the position
types and after 90 of six white um
probably is a little bit better anyway
even though it is a French type of
position but it's hard to get around to
that I mean you can do a play the
exchange to avoid the clothes center
that's really totally totally toothless
so nothing that i would recommend much
yeah well about this game I'm doing
pretty normal stuff let's say and my
opponent is taking ages really ages
there's a question I am 2200 how do i
get to 2400 hmm yeah that depends a lot
on your strengths weaknesses profile
with 2200 of course you're far behind
yeah some some some very standard stuff
that anyone should do like tactics and
so on you have to really look at add
your game what what's what's wrong what
what's good yeah and see where you want
to go do you want to emphasize your
strength or do you want to better better
your weaknesses that's an eternal
question that you have to have to answer
for example if you are let's say
technically sharp player who enjoys
complications then it's an idea maybe
two to tailor your opening repertoire so
that you get those positions mostly on
the other hand you could say that it's
um it's a case where you want to make
sure that you don't have a particular
weakness and then you would have to do
something entirely different it's a it's
hard to tell it's a it's really a very
individual thing yeah people are
completely different this is why chess
is also such a versatile interesting
game it's a nobody is totally alike and
yeah it's not so easy there's no one
very simple recipe for improvement but
what is definitely necessary in any case
is that you that you play I'm quite a
number of games it's impossible to get
serious improvement going without really
playing a huge number of games that sets
it's pretty much clear if i take does he
go before is that too crazy it's a bit
crazy but interesting before hmm
I don't have a great square for that
night hmm how we are this lad not anyway
after take that's a cool idea nitey for
I will be seven that's not possible
probably knight c6 looks really awkward
Wow 9 a-4 looks strange a three was a
cool idea hmm we had I really thought I
had a good position and now I'm that
doesn't doesn't seem to be the case a
three was very strong mmm i'd reached
them I couldn't really find why I
couldn't find the drawback let's say so
is there something that I can do here
and I'd be six is a very the rhetoric of
move I don't know if I have something
better I doubt it let's see if I can
activate my bishop p.m.
yeah I Scott c5f 95 dome I came let's
let's push let's push him I don't think
slow some slow play would help you
that's question is it still true that an
e4 repertoire um is mostly more work
than ad for repertoire hmm um yeah I
still think so at least them at least um
the general yeah it's it yeah I think so
in short I think it's still a little bit
more more work even if you have many
many sidelines in your repertoire um
yeah 95 I wanted to take one I have
three against that move but he's got
rookie three check
what a silly move rupee three Wow I had
such a good position I keep screwing up
good positions here I mean that wasn't
anything particularly great but losing
losing it like that is kind of
frustrating picture 5 yep thank you
while while I playing like a [ __ ] him
there was a very good endgame out of the
opening ah yeah rookie three yeah i saw
that he's putting that on the board but
you have rookies 3 buddy that is I mean
this is just good and wide wins okay so
next game dr. only Targo from Germany
let's get a win in yeah please please
maybe I should have played before and
make something do something crazy okay
what is this kind of a weird
Scandinavian some some weird
Scandinavian what can you do night h6
cool okay
ok I'm going to lash out here normal
normal chest doesn't let me anything
here wait what is he doing after see
hive going back back to the area ok ok
this is this time I'm trying trying it
trying pure aggression hmm ok so what is
this Ponte I can take with the polar can
take the night ok well if I take with
the pawn that all hold you for business
looks kind of kind of crazy yeah let's
take with a night OAS Cup 94 now yeah
I'm just playing I just make too many
mistakes very simple once it's that hmm
ok maybe it's not that terrible but
still
okay at least I'm threatening long
calcium let's do that where are you
going with that night where are you
going I yes to play something weirder
maybe Queen have six or something hmm
weird 95 okay if I take these six anyway
I can take and go at four huh it looks
or Bishop f4 actually is that better
takes Queen takes it's just deadly that
pinner or not I will see how is he not
losing a piece now
I don't see I don't see it now that pin
on the D file and along the f 46
diagonal is kind of strong I really
don't see a move
yeah indie for openings as a question
comparison of a d44 one big difference
between fynd for openings uh Cindy for
openings you have to deal a lot with
trans positions and move orders which
doesn't happen that much with e for
openings with e for pretty much the
first move from decides yeah he resigned
that that was a win the first move
decides what what opening is going to be
played and usually you don't have many
trans positions yeah if they go 1e5
let's say or if they go with a zillion
you won't transpose into a caricom
usually something like that and with D
for openings you have many trans
positions and this makes them learning
1d form at times a bit tricky because
you have to be aware of those trans
positions but on the other hand very
often you can help yourself a little bit
by sorry by am simply understanding
what's going on positions tend to be
closed if there's a bit more in terms of
strategy there yeah so it's a it's a bit
different and in some cases with one
eform you really have absolutely no
alternative to UM to playing um very
sharp lines simply because anything else
just gives you gives you nothing or
gives you problems and deform you have
more chances to play em play lines there
are less committal let's say that's it's
easier with 1d form then with one
earphone okay here we have a pretty
weird Kings onion and align that I don't
really know well but I know that that
that it does exist so let's see um snide
d4 and move here may be very tricky
business yeah let's play something
active
poon that takes taking on divorce it's
not good at all and I'm not quite sure
what he is playing now I mean not that
he has no move but it's kind of
difficult to guess many moves are not
possible at all because they loose
material like we should be five or so or
night XD 495 that I did not expect ok
let's take they see as a question it's a
possibility that you would do again
those top events recaps this year sure
then I'm totally doing those that the
the thing was that the events that that
happened there was the Norway chess
tournament and and Dortmund some yeah as
I was on vacation I simply wasn't around
and I couldn't do it it was my vacation
time I would definitely do um hmm I'd I
will do them sent Lewis some how is it
called the same field cup and I will do
do the other big events there definitely
it's very enjoyable I enjoy doing those
so I would definitely do it again ok
he's attacking f7 him so do I have to
play rupee hive yeah seems to be it's
not ideal but anyway if seven was saying
yeah I was a wave during all of those
top events it was so I for Norway chairs
for for for Dortmund and so on l simply
have totally been away so if I would
have been home I would do the recaps of
course so I'm playing Queen d3 to be
active to activate the Queen attacking
efore I'm a porn down in this position
but this is what I mean with I'm not
technically alert I mean rook t1 is the
most easiest move ever and I didn't even
think about that Wow the worst is that
after Queen a6 he might just play simple
rook g6 and win a pizza
yeah I have no other move and the simple
route is six wins apiece I have no
square for my queen to try to use this
big back rank that's amazing look 26
just wins now okay that that does not
win it might win because I make more
mistakes but Rock t6 was just resigns ok
nice tan SE pone which can be very
dangerous in connection with them with
them with the night so what am i doing
now queen is blocking day poor now mmm
yeah I wonder if I should do something
like a five or if that is a bad idea
it's probably probably very weakening
and therefore Chucky but he has got his
he will come with c6
that's difficult
yeah that's that's probably not good but
I don't I don't see what to do here the
pawn is too strong
d8 splaying Queens is six or something i
can do i can even take a five they're
just a very easy win probably with the
sea porn maybe if he trades queens i get
something with my upon but even that is
a pretty vague hope quince the six is
also probably strong probably
Queen d7 ok I would just ok I got 97 to
try to to try to push the porn home
probably successful name maybe this I
know it's probably lost anyway but
man this is way he covered the rook so
he can just go see seven yeah what's the
problem here c7 well well I want to bet
what a bad stream okay one more game I
really don't want to want to start with
with again with a stop with the loss
again here so that's a question is C
4593 9f 693 night 6d for a bad line
sorry Williams got a new DVD and the
English Way recommends this line but it
looks to us to me hmm young it's
probably nothing much I looked at that
very long time ago and the plane played
it a cup one or two times the tournament
chess but it's like 15 years ago back
then it was pretty toothless it had some
ideas but it wasn't really great so um
but I cannot really commend on that that
DVD by seven Williams I have not seen it
and I don't intend to to get it so um
some difficult too difficult for me I
could have played the Kings gambit
you're right yeah maybe I should have
just for for a sake of getting a crazy
game well maybe I can can can do
something here without castling and
attacking this guy yeah let's go g4
that's probably probably not very good
but anyway the way I'm playing it
probably doesn't matter night if five
okay
so night f1 g 3g five that's the point
case moving what is it doing there ok
wants to go to f4 see ok
I can do night where I can also play gt5
it's quite interesting let's go g5 and I
don't really know if that is so great to
be honest Queen and rookies on yeah but
I can cancel long here let's see what
happens no we had a weird position
that's not not a dull Italian game
sometimes the Italian IAM can be pretty
dull but this is kind of interesting wow
I was really I wanted to go eat five
anyway so what is the point that he
wants to go where to g6 or where
interesting okay I have to prepare that
though on Queen just six i can go Knight
f6 so that's not going to work okay it's
a simple tactic but it is it is there so
ok let's go e5 Queen jus 69 f 619 edge
for him Queen g6 is totally ridiculous
so it goes to be 6 doing what is
attacking f2 ok I can go here right and
before it's also winning the night
almost you can go to this excites not
winning the night ok I can do this so
just the tech is Bishop them
and let's take this okay if I take a g6
you will take d4 prolly it's okay i can
just return i can just return ya see
form I mean especially on a 7 is not
exactly great so what am i doing in my
taking if I taking this thing on g6 or
not why do I go do I go h4 probably h4
h5 is better huh I should only if he
goes b5 and stuff like that then I can
consider to can take with the deep one
and then by Bishop 1 C 2 gets activated
again do I want to take or not maybe I'm
taking it's not a bad idea it takes with
a look at f4 f5 or just g6 ok this one
at f4 f5 now amongst others why canít
take that take that night there with
Queen d2
okay i'm ugly ruling that night over to
e form that cannot be a bad idea i would
be strange if it was a girl aged 6 here
and 94 night to have sex but that cannot
be bad really okay he has to give the
exchange then probably know we does not
give the exchange mm-hmm interesting
there's some way to get rid of that rook
hmm what is he going to do is you're
going to play that should be he'd or
something i don't i don't quite get it
maybe this if it takes with the rook i
have Queen d2 let's a double attack okay
what did I overlook their or nothing
that's a double attack rook on f4 end
the night okay so with what if i take
with this and that that looks a bit
better strategically keeps this nicely
protected so yeah he might take there
but i don't i don't really don't really
care that much i can take only six now
okay if it takes ok I've rupee 7 coming
that's also quite nice so take here yeah
okay so still rookie seven probably that
cannot be bad
so if i go community to I'm threatening
no I'm not threatening her age 70
unfortunate there's some way to directly
threatened stuff he has this check here
yeah anyway for rupee eight I only have
50 seconds
hmm what is that that's a pretty slowish
move takes pawn takes how to leave that
one TV take two takes pawn takes the
screen e5 coming and I'm threatening
rook age 7 Quincy seven here it should
be should be good
and rookie a rookie 8 i'm not sure I'm
threatening that but the truck h7 is a
threat for Quincy cell yes that's one
move that I was a bit concerned about
shoot that's not ideal really not
eyes got Bishop before wow wow wow wow
it's really better to be lucky than good
right
okay so I'm actually winning this this
this bloody game if the time is it's
going to be okay
okay so at least I managed to get a
final final winning ah Wow okay I
already didn't play a good session here
I hope you enjoyed it enjoyed it anyway
at least there was a final funny wild
game there's a question what what's my
opinion about Mike Commerce relentless
attack against the two nights defense
for black in the Italian game he says
it's bad for beginners to allow um I
have no opinion about what mr. camera is
doing I think he the st. Louis chess
club should get rid of this guy simply
has no idea about the game is also
terrible teacher so he should just I
really don't know why they why they
happen especially on video it's simply
simply terrible to watch okay anyway I
hope you still had a good time even
though I didn't play play that well and
then I'm a back online next week
definitely so let's meet next week and
toppa then I'm a little bit better shape
then okay thank you guys for watching
bye